When you're learning English,...
...there are three very important parts of pronunciation.
They are word stress, sentence rhythm and intonation.
Today, we're going to look at the first two,...
...how you can practice word stress and sentence rhythm together...
...to improve your spoken English.
Listen to this sentence closely for word and sentence stress.
I don't think we should blame moderate,...
...intelligent exposure to sunlight throughout our lives...
...as the culprit for markedly increasing our risk of developing skin cancer.
Notice that the speaker uses many words with more than one syllable.
That is common in formal academic language.
But when you come across longer words,...
...you have to learn which syllable to stress.
For example, we say "intelligent", "increasing" and "markedly".
Notice that when you stress one syllable,...
...the vowels in the other syllables are shortened.
Sometimes, these short syllables become a schwa, an 'uh' sound or an 'i'.
They're short, relaxed sounds.
Listen to "moderate", "intelligent", "exposure", "culprit",...
..."markedly", "developing", "cancer".
This shortening of syllables preserves the overall sentence rhythm.
Listen to the clip again.
I don't think we should blame moderate,...
...intelligent exposure to sunlight throughout our lives...
...as the culprit for markedly increasing our risk of developing skin cancer.
Making your spoken English sound natural takes a lot of practice.
Don't forget to listen closely to vowel sounds and sentence stress...
...and remember to practice reading and writing in English every day.
And that's all from me today.
I'll see you next time on Study English, bye!